cool um so i guess what i'm gonna be
talking about isn't necessarily um
revolutionary by any means but i feel
like there's a lot of misinformation
about svg sprites
and uh how they're i i guess used around
the internet and what
how they could be useful what are we
doing here
there we go
that's me
um
cool so right now there's a lot of
problems with like image sprites and
icon fonts and things rendering and
they're slightly um
sort of a pain to set up and there's a
lot of fragmentation across
how uh browsers render them so um both
sizing issues in certain browsers and
edge cases
both the troublesome to position
correctly especially if you're using
like uh custom icon fonts and uh you
sort of have like um
you you know you have to
re-render your icon font every time if
you have a positioning issue or
something like that maybe you should
just get better at rendering the icon
fonts but i don't know i've always found
that to be an issue for me
um and anti-aliasing is always different
between browsers especially when you hit
mobile devices and android um
i found that to be quite a big issue so
what are svg sprites so it's pretty
simple and svg sprite is just a single
svg file
that contains data from multi uh from
multiple svg graphics um
they're convenient because they serve
with one http request
they are simple to position
while you side with them with css
they're easy to add to your workflow um
and it's really easy to create fallbacks
for them in fact i think there's a lot
of grunt and gulp
tasks that help you do this so what does
a svg sprite look like
so
an svg sprite kind of uh looks like this
is basically an svg
uh that's printed out
um there's a few key things that are
different here uh first off we're using
symbol tag for each sprite instead of
the g tag and this
the g tag is um stands for group and it
typically comes from
like a
like an image rendering program that
would group together paths or elements
so in illustrator when you
have items that are grouped together it
would surround those with a g tag when
it's exported
in replacing that with the symbol tag
the symbol tag is actually able to
create its own view box that's separate
so this way you can set separate view
box elements
um
for each sprite so a different image is
a different size you can set that here
uh in the view box which is kind of nice
um
also with the symbol tag it allows you
to set a title and description i don't
have that here but um you can use a
title tag and a description tag that
works well with accessibility
um so with the symbol tags it's easier
to make them responsive obviously
because you can set your view box within
here and then the
um
sprite can
readjust from there um
cool so creating svg sprite
you can copy and paste from manual
individual svg files there's a few grunt
and gulp tasks that do it for you grant
svg store
will create them for you from a folder
of
svg files
current icon will create ping
fallbacks for your svg files and i found
this one recently
uh dr svg sprites which
compiles a folder for you and then
creates a ping spreadsheet also which
seems pretty convenient it didn't have a
lot of
attention it was a github repo that i
found um i'll post a link to this slide
so you guys can click on these links
um
and that seemed kind of interesting i'm
playing around with it with a little bit
i think it needs a little bit more
betting but um
yeah there's also a few services that
make it really easy to do uh fantastic
akumu and fontello will print out svg
sprites for you
um which is pretty nice and they even
allow you to upload your own
so using an svg sprite so this is a
basic html page
um so here at the top we're defining
the uh
sprite i guess the svg so there's our
two um
symbols and then down here
uh in our page we're left we're able to
use the svg use tag to call
the
sprite so there's the sprite up there
we're calling the id of icon one and
we're saying use
link hf icon one this can also work with
external um
uh files which is kind of nice
um the
initial svg has to be called
at the beginning of the document um
i believe there's a
funny chrome bug right now that makes
it not possible to call in the footer
but i believe that's being fixed in
chrome 37 i saw i don't know i'm not
sure about that um
so uh svg um
use tags calls the width hyphen v box
that it's set like i said um elements
that render inside the use tag is
treated as shadow dom
is that correct
all right
i talked i taught dominic something
um
it uh yeah fun fact uh svg was used in
the rcc specification or until like
first time we went to shadow dom like
over a decade ago it showed up in 2003
i think it was interesting i like
started reading over this spec
just to see what they're trying to do
here and uh it was very ambitious they
were like sort of creating a
like a they were like creating a
rendering engine inside of a rendering
engine and it just didn't work and so
that's why it kind of disappeared i
think
i
yeah not too sure uh requires a fallback
to work in ie but basically what you'll
do to make the fallback happen in ie is
replace svg use with an object tag which
will re-render it twice but
um
i i don't know um i feel like the
trade-off is worth it um
um
yeah it doesn't work in all the way up
to ie11 which is kind of unfortunate
uh
so here we have a demo um
so essentially here's our html page with
our
symbol tags here
calling the svg sprite down here
so i have two different sprites i have
icon 1 and icon 2.
so if i change this to
icon
i'll get the other svg sprite
so it's pretty cool
and then there's a few other things we
can do you can um add styling to um
the uh
individual sprites so you can style them
each differently which is kind of cool
so i think that's pretty neat you can
style them separately
uh make it easier
uh
inside your svg file there's also a defs
tag which is your define tag um it
allows you to define an element without
rendering it
so this can be used to store anything
essentially so it can store
patterns gradients or masks
it's great for creating like sort of
minimal templates for things that you
want to reuse within your svg sprites
this is especially helpful if you're
handcrafting your svgs or making it in a
program like inkscape or illustrator
so the depth tag looks like this
essentially
so we're inside of our def tag we're um
basically establishing a linear gradient
here uh it just starts at white ends of
black
and it's printing out into a circle here
and so our fill
is given the url of this gradient
so within our svg file we can reference
things it's sort of like making sas
mixins you know how those work
inside of a svg file so it's pretty
convenient the way you can manipulate
these and sort of set it up in a
different svg elements um
i don't know i'm not sure um
you can cool that's great
okay
yeah imagine if you can reference it
from externally it would be similar is
that right or it's just like a document
okay that's weird because it's
definitely a different documented space
you'd have to change this url value i
imagine or no uh no if you put a closed
svg before the circle okay
yeah
oh okay i see
great
uh demo
so
essentially um
that's this here i'm dealing with a
different object here this is a
pattern that's just being created with
the path that's being defined and it's
being printed out into a rectangle here
so here is our
results
um
don't no longer have internet i think i
have the uh
here we go so here's our result here
that's the same file sorry about that
you never see that okay how that kind of
works so you can just have a basic
rectangle with a width and height of 200
and fill it with the pattern that you
referenced here
um yeah
so
i believe that is uh all does anyone
have any questions on how to implement
these or
oh yeah
is it possible to use a whole different
svg to reference a whole different svg
document instead of
the uh
sorry what was the first example of the
first tag that you're using
uh yeah where was that back the civil
tag yesterday
so are you talking about separate files
or separate svgs
uh this one here
yeah
probably it sounds like from what you
were saying earlier the ids are movable
across the html file right yeah i
believe they should be so you can
reference them from multiple documents
all right i don't know any other
questions here did you say it didn't
work 11 or the fallback didn't work the
fallback works in i11 but the this svg
used does not work in ie11 it falls back
to the object tag
any other questions
no that's all
all right cool